hello and welcome to my top do it life
it's your downtime migration to GCP I'm
Sean Michael Lewis I'm principal
software engineer at Fitbit and I was in
charge of moving our monolithic
application from our legacy managed
hosting to Google cloud platform today's
talk I want to talk about what was
unique or what we felt was unique about
this bits migration challenge we're
talked about how we thought about users
in making decisions to move for our
migration then we'll talk about the
technology and processes that we added
and affected to make this happen we'll
talk a little bit about how it went
which was quite well and then we'll have
some takeaways that we think could be
useful for you should you be moving from
another cloud provider or your own
managed hosting into Google cloud
platform so like many companies Fitbit
started with a monolithic application we
had a single binary that they did all
the things it is quite large it does it
handles all of our traffic or it did for
a long time over and then we started to
break it up into what we call micro
service this is pretty pretty standard
when a company matures what while moving
micro services might be quite easily
each service couldn't do its own thing
move its own data store figure things
out and move into the cloud the monolith
is much more challenging it's a more
challenging
it's bigger meteor it takes up about 70%
of our traffic so moving it was quite
hard so our migration wasn't going to
happen until the monolith move so let's
talk about our monolith like I said it's
a single Java binary about a thousand
instances backed by around 200 my sequel
instances those my sequences are mostly
charted by user data so if request comes
in I can get all of my data from one
shard
we have a sharding library that manages
the shards so it allows you to figures
out where users go when new users sign
up if figure it allows you to expand and
contract the number of my sequences we
have and it also handles caching
which we had around 400 nodes of
memcache we also have Kafka where we do
asynchronous processing and those
messages are largely processed by other
instances within the monolith so we'll
talk about yeah we'll talk about our
users now now that we know what the
application looks like we thought about
what it would look like for us to move
and who we should be thinking about as
we're moving the most important
stakeholder in the move is your users
sometimes doing the best thing for users
is not the most easy thing technically
but that should be the thing you do
first the person you think about first
so how do we get to GCP with our users
in mind we thought about two different
ways of doing this one was to do it
progressively so move user by user or
batch of user by batch of user what we
could do it all at once there are
different pros and cons to each for the
progressive we thought that anything bad
that happened in the new environment as
we were moving any new challenge that we
experienced in our new in our new home
would be limited to only the mover users
that have moved so it's be a smaller
impact overall to our user base as we
figure it out things in the new
environment secondly like outside of you
know normal availability problems like
just how our application tend to look in
the new environment would be able to be
observed in a more gradual fashion we
can see how the environment dealt with
new load in a more measured way we knew
that Network called we wouldn't be able
to make every network called being the
new data in the new data center in GCP
so we would have to go back to the old
data center sometimes and that would
incur a lot of latency that's not a
great user experience but it's you know
one of the downsides this approach and
then lastly we'd have to operate to full
application stacks simultaneously be
able to operate them at the same time
and manage them at the same time in two
data centers and two different hosting
idioms for us on the contrary the
all-in-one solution any challenges you
have in the new environment when you
should come over to the new environment
it affects everyone so if you have a big
outage everyone's down if
it's basically a total system shock
there's a lot of risk in that you can do
a lot of testing beforehand but you
don't know what's really gonna happen
till youth look to switch the positive
is that once you're in the new data
center all of your network calls are
local so your latency situation is good
as it's going to be and while you don't
have to maintain and operate two data
centers at the same time you need the
old one on standby in case something
goes wrong in the move so you're not
really getting rid of the old one when
you cut over at least until you're fully
in so which one did we choose we felt
that overall thinking of the users in
mind that the progressive migration was
going to be much better for them on
average most users wouldn't experience
any downtime or any noticeable Valentine
that took some work but we thought that
if we could you know slowly roll into
GCP we would give our users the best
experience and maybe even when they
don't notice so as we were thinking
about how we're going to do this
progressive migration we had to think
about what are the things we want out of
it how are we going to do it can be our
guiding principles so the first one was
to make you a best effort to route users
the environment where their data is
resident as I said we found our data out
by user so if if I move my data from our
old hosting to GCP I should start
routing my request to GCP that was the
goal of this migration is to move the
user with the data we wanted to make
sure that what's say we didn't route
correctly and my data isn't GCP but I
got routed to the old data center well
that should still work we still want
that to be an experience if you don't
want to be throwing errors when we have
a Mis rel so we wanted an experience no
matter what we wanna be able to move
users to DCP but if things aren't going
well we need to be able to move them
back and we also need to be movable to
use variable speed if things are going
great we should be able to move users
more quickly if they're not going so
we're not sure we should trickle them in
and get our sea legs as it were lastly
as we were making these decisions about
fast slow forward backwards we don't
be making a lot of like gut-check
decisions we want to be able to look at
a chart and say we're meeting in RSL
Lowe's we're gonna have to move forward
now and so we actually needed to develop
more SOS and have a better handle on
them before we could do this
appropriately talk about the timeline
for this migration so as I said we want
to move users slow and quickly at
different varying times but before that
we needed to actually set everything up
in GCP make sure it was working and you
can always run tests but until you're
really routing production users there
it's not it's not real
so the first users that we routed were
employees we routed them through GCP all
their data was still in our old data
center they had slow experiences but at
the beginning a lot of things were
broken but we fixed bugs until we had a
complete experience and all the
meaningful experiences that happen in
Fitbit were serviceable by going through
GCP and even if data was in another data
center once we felt confident in that we
decided it was time to start moving
paying customers so we started moving
users slowly in a slow trickle when we
got to watch as our systems took on that
new traffic and make sure that we were
able to operate it murder and really you
know make sure that things were working
in GCP then once we got a lot of
confidence we started moving users in
big batches we moved them quickly and as
you'll see quicker than we even
anticipated so how did we change our
architecture and technology to make this
kind of move possible I don't see on the
left I had the same diagram for a
monolithic architecture for our legacy
data center we've replicated that in
Google cloud platform so the whole thing
up we had fewer application instances at
the star fewer my sequel instances but
and those my sequel instances were empty
when we started as well because they had
no data in them there was no data in GCP
yet and then we had connections from all
the application instances to all the my
sequels both the old datacenter and in
GCP so there's fully connected between
those two data centers between
application instances
those are the blue lines you'll see the
application instances go - those are the
lines that we had to add we had to add
connections back to the old data center
from GCP and to GCP from the old data
center then we added edge routing as
well this was the logic that would allow
us to route users based on where they
lived so we had to be able to push that
logic somewhere it turns out we use
CloudFlare which is ca CDN and DNS
provider they had a product called cloud
flower workers that we were able to push
logic up into you and make these
decisions now I'll talk more about that
later but that I made it so that we
didn't have to go into one datacenter to
decide that we really want to service it
out the other one and kick it back and
redirect it made everything much cleaner
and easier to observe as well and then
lastly we have connectivity between our
memcache instances you'll notice that
the app we in this diagram the
applications only talk to their data
center of little local memcached but if
one application if one data center makes
change to its local memcache we want
that change to be replicated to the
other one and so we introduced a proxy
that allow us to echo and validations to
the other data center I'll talk about
that as well first we'll talk about
moving up users I said we had initially
empty databases in GCP and all the full
databases and our legacy data center in
our charting scheme we have this notion
of buckets buckets have users in them
mostly there's only really two ways to
do sharding there's buckets and there's
ID ranges we use buckets it's kind of
like a hashing scheme but it allows us
to move an individual bucket one at a
time so we can move one bucket to any
other database server so when we were
moving into GCP we could move one bucket
from a database server that lived in our
old data center and then move it to GCP
now the users have been moved this is
the slow method of movement it takes
about 20 minutes because there's a lot
of locking involved users can still read
their data but they can't write for that
20 minutes it's slow and gradual we can
add
to get a little bit more speed and so we
can do many buckets at a time but we
can't really move tons of users at once
to move fast we will move the whole
shard and this is a typical replication
strategy which is that our leader
database would be in our old datacenter
we'd have a replica of it in GCP some
point we would flip who the leader was
and make the leader the one in GCP now
all the users on that shard all those
buckets have shifted all at once and
that is a very fast thing it takes about
five minutes it can go back and forward
both of them are bi-directional which is
important for our use case I'll talk a
little bit about routing as I said
CloudFlare workers is the technology we
used to provide some logic as to where
user traffic should be routed so we have
this idea of buckets as I told you about
there's a finite number of buckets in
fact the number was finite enough that
we could make a big map of it and push
that that map in a JavaScript binary up
to this CloudFlare worker we could also
put a whitelist in there which allowed
us how we were able to route employees
before paying customers so regardless of
where your data is resident we could say
oh this user should always go to GCP no
matter what no matter where their data
is otherwise see where their bucket
lives so this is a flow diagram we have
time deployments of the logic the code
that executes the logic but also the
data that feeds that logic gets time to
deploy into into CloudFlare then the
logic is simply is the user in the
whitelist if so said under the GCP if
not check where their bucket lives is
the bucket in GCP if yes and then the
GCP if not or we have some kind of error
or there's no user information send them
to the legacy data center eventually
even once we have more than 50% of
movement into GCP we made the default
GCB
the last technical aspect was keeping
the caches cool here as I said
applications only talk to their local
caches and if the other data center
changes the cache on their side you want
it to be reflected in both places so we
introduced a new piece of technology
McCotter an open-source memcache proxy
that has the ability to echo echo
deletes and other operations to other
data centers or other clusters of
memcache nodes our second cluster just
happened to be other the other data
center so we this was a pretty
challenging for us although it's a
pretty straightforward and it's a good
tool we don't think a lot about it now
too stark difference from implementing
the routing from before the routing of
being a managed service ended up being
really easy for us to do give us very
few headaches with very few incidents
around it
whereas introducing a new piece of
technology just before you make a big
move was much more challenging and ended
up working off for us but it started to
show us the differences between what
might be possible when we have more
managed services that our disposal so
how did this all go it actually went
quite well better than I think any of us
expected
we the routing of employees before
everyone else uncovered many critical
bugs so uncovered around 60 bugs we
closed 58 of them before we move to a
paying customer and I think those other
two got closed as won't fix they didn't
end up being that critical so really
everything that was really blocking an
experience in GCP was closed before we
were able to do it and we did that like
live we were didn't in production I mean
we tested it in production without
affecting our paying customers
which was super awesome and then we also
finished early we we had a pretty hard
deadline to be out at a certain time and
we started this process if you look at
the left of this graph you'll see that
there's a very slow - a very low trickle
of information of throughput going to GC
P which is the Green Line you'll see
that it slowly steps up over time and
then around the end of August
8:30 on this chart you'll see it takes a
big step up and then it takes some other
bigger steps up and stays high we you
know based on our SLO is we were able to
see that we were doing well everything
was kind of under control and then we
can really push this migration faster
and get done sooner than we expected
which was super exciting for everyone so
what are the takeaways from this process
progressive migration is based on you
turday user data locality can provide
the best user experience for your users
most of the time you probably if you
have a sharded model if like we do you
probably have some sort of user Rashard
or something like that
and so if you can do it little by little
that's going to be the best bang for
your buck your movement should have
options both directions both speed and
direction it gives you flexibility for
when things go wrong or things go really
well decide what is really good or
really well based on your SLO and then
also we found that this was the first
opportunity for us having been in our
own Colo to use managed services and
really see the benefit of them now that
we're in Google cloud platform we think
there's a lot more opportunities for us
to do that so if you there are
opportunities to use them in your
migration I would I would I would say
you should that's all thank you very
much for your time and I hope your
migration goes well as well